in Australia milder weather conditions
for the next few days are expected to
help firefighters battling dozens of
massive wildfires that killed more than
two dozen people since September on
Friday crew struggled against high winds
that whipped up already dangerous
conditions air tankers dropped fire
retardant on fires near some of the most
populated areas where two fires merged
those fires have burned more than a
million acres in the southeast Jamie
yuccas reports now from one hard-hit
area good morning this is one of nearly
3,000 homes damaged or destroyed by
Australia's wildfires there are still
more than a hundred fires burning right
now including a mega blaze the size of
Delaware haunting images flames plumes
of smoke and firefighters desperately
battling walls of fire
weather conditions deteriorated once
again going into the weekend along the
southeastern coast of Australia a
quarter of a million people were asked
to evacuate but instead many prepared to
protect their homes with hoses did you
evacuate last time we did and you're not
evacuating this time that's right
why yes because way they seek out
through eating and living it puts a lot
of stress on everybody many fires were
kept under control but in the thick
brush of Australia's mountain ranges two
fires merged into a one and a half
million acre blaze firefighters say the
flames are taking hold because of record
droughts inspector Phil Sheedy has been
a firefighter for three decades in 33
years you've never seen conditions like
this
not obvious no no no it's um the
duration and severity and and just you
know the magnitude of them is just
incredible I've seen trees that would
you know up since to be looking
healthy-looking tree with a bit of
firewood space and they just come down
really quick because the soil is so dry
hundreds of Australians are starting to
sift through the rubble of their still
smoldering homes returning to
smog-filled towns I couldn't say the
smoke was so thick and empty stores very
vacuum by the tourists that's without
income which is all that cream in that
profit the world is watching it all
unfold and trying to help in any way
they can
veteran firefighters from California
arrived in Australia
earlier this week - Cheers there's also
an all-out effort to save Australia's
animals it's estimated nearly a billion
animals species found nowhere else in
the world have died just get the hit out
okay like a baby
Jan Chien is caring for orphan wallaby
sisters who need to eat every four hours
we're gonna feed them yep all the
Wallabies and kangaroos are lactose
intolerant so we have to feed them a
special formula she seems to like it
Julie Taylor Mills has converted her
property into a mini Animal Sanctuary
what do we have here this is a redneck
wallaby Mills is caring for two
Wallabies and a peridot is just a
for weeks she built fences and planted
grass since the rest of her property has
been impacted by the severe drought
Mills has also been forced to evacuate
twice no one knows yet what the impact
of these fires are going to be in terms
of Australian biodiversity so properties
like this and people like that who
rescue animals like this may will be
really crucial going forward grassroots
efforts to save some of Australia's most
famous faces while others fight for a
future down under this is just the
beginning of fire season now the
Australian military is on standby to
help firefighters but the good news is
better weather conditions are expected
over the next week with wetter and
cooler temperatures predicted for CBS
this morning Saturday Jamie yuccas when
jellow Australia it's just amazing that
this has been going on since October and
I know there are so many people that are
affected but I can't help those images
of the animals every time I see them and
is just absolutely soul-crushing
yeah and the biodiversity of that
continent is is is just extraordinary
and to have witnessed it you know
firsthand is really a treasure so the
idea of it no longer being there in some
parts that's tough and the number of
animals still in danger and again people
- there are so many it's just it is that
impact that lasting impact
you